the emphasis here will be all small and
uh
here is an example this is the adjacency
matrix 150 nodes
these three subgroups they are you know
the first 20 nodes then the next
15 then the following 10 and here you
can probably see them by eye
edge probability inside is 0 7 and
inside is 0
3 okay and
okay if you didn't see them before here
it's clearer of course they are not
ordered and the difficulties in finding
them now
try to stare at it will you find them
okay and and what i want to talk about
is
two things i want efficient algorithms
and here
efficient will mean for me nearly a
linear time
that is n square log n if n is the
number of vertices
and i want a provable improvement over
spectral methods
there is a standard way of doing this
you know just take the metrics that i
show and
compute the svd now they are given by
the composition
i want to try to improve that
and this is the outline i will start by
reviewing spectral methods and
i spend a little bit of time of why they
fail and then
talk about something beyond that that
are called non-linear power
iteration and then how can you do proof
theorems about it
there is a paper that is out there that
is
part of this work another party will
come out at some point
okay and in fact i will you know
consider a very simple example
really simple a lot can be generalized
so a
big thing k nodes here
and nodes here i want to find these k
nodes and
k is much smaller than n
okay okay
it's more or less the statement of the
problem clear i went very quickly where
it
so there's no assumption in the rest of
the graph
yeah so i know i'll make all the
possible bad assumptions
so here nodes are present with priority
queue
and here they're present with priority p
edges are present
and you know we can talk about relaxing
these assumptions
but this is not what i want to focus on
yeah
n squared i mean linear i would expect
in the number of edges
yeah i want linear in the number of
edges
m squared and square logan
so here i'm thinking okay okay
m log n if you want as you will see
what we'll talk about is things that
take the same time some matrix vector
multiplication
where this is the matrix okay so it's
really like a number of edges
like we'll see okay some of the things
yes some no
you can't think pfq are constant for for
simplicity you know it's
that hard enough constant
that that's that's the question right of
course
okay uh so let's see let's see what
happens
so the right way to think about this is
okay
called gd adjacency metrics and uh
what what is easy to see is that the
expectation of g is what
well it's p here and q there so this is
the all one matrix is all one
and then there is you know perturbation
this that is p minus q
times you know this is the indicator
vector over
s times its transpose
so this is the expectation so
and this variance is okay apart from the
click is constant is q1 minus q
so in fact it's convenient once you look
at this to to work with the different
metrics that is subtract from the
adjacency matrix
this part the background q times
you know the all one matrix and then
rescale it
okay and then scale it in such a way
that each entry
now has variance one over n
okay that's the if you think a little
bit about it that's really the natural
scaling of this stuff
so here q is given
also let's say that is given we can uh
we can we can talk about that also
but let's say for simplicity is given
um
okay so so if you think about once you
do this normalization what happens this
matrix well this matrix is
very simple is a rank one matrix
that you can think of as the signal this
is
this piece once you're scaled is a rank
one sparse matrix
plus another part that has zero mean
and in fact has iid entries
and i want to think of this as the noise
so i want to think of this problem as
i have a rank one matrix plus noise and
i want to estimate this
rank one matrix okay and of course you
can already imagine how you can
go about generalizing this if you have k
clusters this will be
you know around k metrics plus noise
so this is a type of random matrices
that has been studied in all
in a lot of details in probability
theory
under the name of low rank deformation
of beginner matrices very precise things
are known about the eigenvalues of this
and eigenvector of these matrices and
this is the most important single most
important bit of information
and unlike in other estimation problems
like there is
where there is signal and noise and you
know somehow performances degrade
slowly with the signals to noise ratio
here there is an interesting phase
transition okay
if the signal noise ratio is below a
critical value
and that critical value appears to be
equal to one
if you look at the spectrum of this
matrix or better the spectral
density this is the wigner law okay so
this is the distribution of eigenvalues
all the eigenvalues were going to be
between two and minus two
and their distribution follows this big
number
all right further if you look at the top
eigenvector of this matrix this is
basically orthogonal
to the vector that you want to
reconstruct so in this regime there is
basically no
use in doing principal component
analysis you can
now forget about it if lambda is bigger
than one things change
dramatically there is one eigenvector
that pops out
is that lambda plus one over lambda
beautiful formula
and it has a positive scalar product
with
the stuff that you want to reconstruct
so in this regime
if you you know do principal component
analysis
pull the largest eigenvector this will
not get you precisely
the community or you know the vector the
rank one metrics that you want to
reconstruct it
but will have positive correlation and
you can hope of improving over it
so is this clear yeah so now
okay uh so now the question this
phenomenon is really at the basis and
various generalizations and deformation
and belts and whistles
you know of a large number of algorithms
you know
in this in the problems of finding
clicks in random graph actually dates
back to a paper a
very nice paper by along cleveland
soudakov
where they showed the following that if
k is bigger than
sufficiently big constant times square
root of n
then you can reconstruct this community
correctly uh in community detection it
was
studied uh it's you know a building
block of spectral clustering
uh et cetera et cetera et cetera okay
okay so now the question that i want to
ask is really
can we beat this
threshold this spectral threshold that
is can
we find you know estimate this vector u
when lambda is less than one
okay so if we go back to our uh
original setting graph setting this
means for
p minus q or the theta of 1
this means for k smaller than square
root of n
so if you look at this this setting
really the spectral
threshold is a p minus q that is
so this threshold in the graph example
turns out to be
that threshold turns out to be this i
think
okay so can we get below this threshold
either in p minus q order one or p minus
q smaller
okay and what is the basic intuition the
equation just to pass that formula so
when k
is equal to root n and essentially p
minus q
so you're saying in that case when
there's a constant gap between p minus q
you can recover
yeah so so so okay this statement about
spectral methods what it
tells you is that if k times p minus q
is bigger than square root of n
times q one minus q
okay pca works
if it is smaller it doesn't
okay so along cleveland chancellor cup
they looked at p equal one
q equal one half in that case it gives
this threshold okay and they actually
proved if k
is bigger than a big enough constant
okay and why why there can be hope
okay why there should be hope uh
well one reason why there should be hope
is that this is okay is the principal
eigenvector of a matrix
but is a principal again vector with a
very special structure
first of all it's non-negative and
second is very sparse
okay so can we use non-negativity
and sparsity to beat this kind of
phenomenon
okay so this is what i want to try to
understand
and in principle there should be a huge
you know possibility or
purely from an information theoretical
point of view you can reconstruct it as
as soon as k is bigger than logan
okay so so there are various ideas for
going beyond the spectral methods there
is a bunch of methods that use
convex relaxation there is idea in
pca that use power iteration and there
is ideas that use graphical model
methods like belief propagation etc
uh none of these
you know all of this has very
interesting uh you know ideas but
none of these has provable improvements
over this threshold
and in fact i must say very little
because for instance there is this work
by
hanan floran and you know chris murray
other in which they prove that using a
certain belief propagation algorithm
in certain classes of sparse graph you
can actually
improve our spectrum
so what do you mean by improvement that
you can correctly identify it under that
purple
okay so what is the idea of nonlinear
power iteration
ideas the following take the normalized
adjacency matrix
hit a vector with it ideally this should
correlate with your
leading eigenvector but then somehow use
it
use the fact this fact that x you know
the leading edge
vector is known to be sparse by applying
some nonlinear function
so at each iteration now computing the
leading eigenvector corresponds to
multiply
you know repeatedly by this adjacency
matrix a
here what i'm doing is that i'm
multiplying by a and then
you know somehow using some nonlinear
function to
eliminate the excess noise
and here i want to look at a separable
nonlinear function the tax component by
component
so this is one example in fact i will
look at these three examples
for instance one possible idea could be
you know i i want to look for an
eigenvector that is non-negative
so i teach iteration i multiply by a
and instead you know unlike in normal
power method
i set to zero all the entries that are
negative
another idea could be i want to look for
a sparse eigenvector
so i multiply by a and then i keep only
all
those entries that are above a certain
threshold
or you could decide that you want to use
some soft rule
okay this will skip so this is something
that is present in some form in the
literature for instance this paper by
one
and zhang and here i'll show you some
simulation that are in terms of this
parameter
epsilon that is the size of the hidden
click or the hidden community and these
are for you know doing fifth iteration
and for a matrix of one thousand by one
thousand
so this is what for each point here i
have a grid of values of epsilon and
lambda
and for each point i compute the
scalar product between the vector that i
want to reconstruct
and what i estimate all right so this is
lambda
besides the signal to noise ratio and
this is epsilon the sparsity
and this is a scale between 0 1 so you
see that
small epsilon is good a large lambda is
good
this is the spectral threshold
this is the spectral pressure so you see
that you can do a little bit more for
instance for very sparse
you know instances you can do a little
bit more than
you know the spectral threshold that is
one you can move a
a constant below that at least
empirically so the upshot here is that
you know this kind of methods seem
empirically to be better than spectra
in fact they are very much used in
practice of course there is a couple of
sources of criticism here first how do
you pick this nonlinear
function and second can you quantify
this improvement
yeah um
yeah i think that actually is a glitch
in the program we did the simulation
last
last week and i still don't believe them
i don't i believe this and this and you
see why and
i don't believe this but it might okay
we'll see
it's it's not crucial right okay so now
i'll explain a slightly different
algorithm
and uh you know how to predict actually
say things about this car of course
analyzing this kind of algorithms is a
nightmare because
there is all sorts of dependencies
popping out after any number of
direction i mean one can do you know
rough stuff but not very precise
asymptotics
all right so this is my my my algorithm
i apply nonlinear function then i
multiply by a
planar linear function i do one simple
modification that is subtracting
a memory term all right so this is not
whatever in memory term
is a memory time for which we have an
explicit formula you can find it out
and you know this explicit formula is
basically
chosen to cancel the the correlation
between the estimated time t
plus one and the estimates at all
previous time so the correlates
this by this there is magically one
specific coefficient that does
does it and the fixed point of these
algorithms can be related to
stationary point of cost functions of
this form this is the natural cost
function that you would try to
optimize from a maximization point of
view for instance
if you want to use positivity you can
use here regularizer that forces
x to be non-negative if you just
minimize this you can
you get standard pca if you do this you
get
you know and if you do the positive part
iteration like this
it your fixed points are stationary
points of this
there is also a graph interpretation
that okay
okay i will say it quickly if you look
there is a connection with all the story
about the graftons etc
if you look at the teeth the rate of
this
this is really a weighted sum over graph
embeddings
over in in this graph g
gi okay for instance the line you know
that linear power iteration
is essentially counting the number of
paths root at the time
your graph this is counting not paths
but
three and this with very specific set of
weights
okay so i think that there is an
interesting connection there that
this is the difference between you know
so this is what we call approximate
message passing for reason that i will
not explain
this is the difference between the
previous power iteration and this
there is a little improvement uh here
there is an improvement but i don't know
whether it is because there was a glitch
so this is here there is a little
improvement
but this is not the crucial thing the
crucial thing here is that
now i have a formula to predict the
asymptotic behavior of this power
iteration
and hereby asymptotic i mean end to
infinity
s t fixed so here it is say 50.
so this is you know the prediction this
is a formula that
gave me this plot and this is what
simulation
given and you see that you get you know
very close
phenomena here you have some threshold
here here it works a little bit better
in theory that in practice
so this experiment shows that the series
is much better than
the experiment it's it's it's a bit
better if you look at it more closely
for larger size
the theory is not much better they're
actually you know
fairly close especially in the sparse
regime and what we have is that
asymptotically they coincide
okay so from this so there is explicit
formula for these
plots here but i want to pull out a few
things that you can learn for instance
using this formula
okay this is for instance one thing
right so this is in this paper with
yash if you use this base
optimal non-linearity you can prove that
you can reconstruct
you know the set tests for p minus q of
order one
as soon as p minus q is bigger than
square root of n
q my one minus q over e okay
so if you compare with what pca does
you see that we have beaten you know
principal component phase transition
and we are beaten exactly by factor
square root of v
okay so this you know celebrated
spectral phase transition seems to have
a base analogous and this base analogous
is
shifted in fact we can
you know wonder what happens if you just
use non-negativity so you want to
reconstruct
any principal vector that is
non-negative turns out that this
positive part iteration does it as soon
as lambda
is bigger than one over square root of
two okay so the standard pca
phase transition is at signals to noise
ratio equal one
if you know that your principal
component is non-negative
it moves to one over square root of two
so square root of two better than
spectral you know asymptotically we can
prove that
if epsilon is above a certain number
that is above
0.5 there is no algorithm that can do
better than
the base version of this algorithm
so what about the issue so they can
run their things several times and get
constant time scroll them for instance
good point okay so this
you were referring to this yes but this
is
you know this is for clicks of sides
clicks that are not clicks there's four
sets that are sides five percent
times n and now p minus q
are very close if p minus q are far
apart things are
trivial now you take p and q that are
within one over square root of n
this is the interesting regime and now
i'm telling you
that you know no method to do
can do better than this of course if you
are interested in
very small things then this doesn't
apply
but
okay that saves me a question and this
is one more thing i gave you this
kind of optimization principle you know
this algorithm has fixed point as you
know stationary point of this cost
function
this is one cases in which we can prove
convergence to the minimum of this com
function consider the following
if you know that you're again vector and
non-negative you might want to maximize
the rayleigh ratio
subject to the eigenvector be
non-negative
okay this is a beautiful interesting
problem of course
it's non-convex so it's difficult we can
prove that within this model
this algorithm actually solves this
the problem there's no convex problem
without probability
okay okay there is an underlying theory
beyond all of these these are not four
examples but come from
some theorem that implies all of them
uh just one conclusion uh
yeah uh in the very sparse regime
uh okay first of all you know arguably
for this type of problem you cannot
improve
more than theta here we improved by
constants over spectrum method we went
down from
for instance finding clique with lambda
equal one to finding clip
with lambda equal one over square root
of n probably you cannot improve more
than a constant
in polynomial time there is results by
fighting cloud gamer
and by uh with gerson and mecca that
kind of point very strongly at this
so since you cannot improve by constants
more than constants is important to kind
of try to understand
you know very precisely how the
constants behave
and okay this is an open problem
since the emphasis here was an open
problem
here you know in the special case of
clicks so p equal one
and q equal one off we can find the
click
of sides k equals square root of n over
e
in nearly linear time in n square log n
iteration
uh i think it's a nice challenge to try
to do better
man i i'll buy you a dinner if you can
thanks
any quick uh clarification for laughter
heart from this there's all kinds of
results but if you ask
me what he sings i don't think you can
call it okay i don't know what fortified
the things yeah he doesn't even claim
that
but they don't they have some analysis
of linear programming relaxation
yeah yeah so the biggest omega was
supposedly
sdp relaxation yeah so these people are
analyzed shirelli adam's relaxation and
i didn't know that the paper of white
person is bugged but
supposedly they analyzed the lasser
relaxation they showed that you cannot
leave
so the approximate message passing it
looks like
i mean it feels like an iteration of
piston for instance
yeah it's similar to many things that
appear in
convex optimization and don't really you
know i wasn't ever
able to match it precisely into one and
the reason is that here
okay in this this thing there is a very
specific choice of
first of all this function that we use
here can be anything
okay okay so now you can take them it to
be the prox operator of something and
then
right but then in general this bt in
general there is no precise prescription
except that it has to be i don't know in
some range
uh here there is a very precise
prescription and if you don't use that
precise prescription all the asymptotic
theory that we use breaks down and that
precise prescription is really
you know you look at the correlation
induced on this
you know between this object and this
object and basically you find the
precise coefficient that cancels those
correlations but bt is independent of
the previous iterations you can think of
it as a deterministic quantity if you
want
when you say base what do you mean okay
so so this is this uh slide that i kind
of
skipped uh
you can do okay one way to derive this
is to write
uh the posterior on the variable given
the observation
write this as a graphical model so it's
kind of a bayesian point of view and
write the belief propagation algorithm
for this graphical model
and then you know this is this this is
what you get from this belief
propagation algorithm for
you know you do a certain number of
approximation of it that should be
asymptotically correct but you don't use
any particular prior
yeah okay so here here are the prior for
this function that you use
so perhaps you didn't notice here but
this is a logistic
but in china if you know the prior you
could change the thresholding
so there is something interesting this
is mini max in some class of course
so we're eating into the coffee time so
let's take the other clear
questions offline or you can bring them
back up in the discussion
but let's cut back at three o'clock